we're very proud of the development here  and obviously offering up a new  freestanding emergency department for  this area we've seen a consistent amount  of growth  from a north las vegas perspective in  terms of overall population  and housing growth and so this  development will certainly help to  better support the growing needs of this  community  the facility itself is about 10 000  square feet in total  in terms of space in terms of patients  and patient rooms we have  six treatment bays and additional three  other bays available so total of nine  patient bays available for for patient  treatment and so we can serve quite a  few patients in terms of from a time  perspective and  and community needs perspective